au soir florence foresti au ses hôtes
satisfaction bah c'est beau un
appartement ranger il n'y a pas de chien
il ya pas de joie de chiens ya rien là
bas d'ado n'y a pas de la douce
est-ce que je peux m'installer quelques
joueurs et non parce qu'il faut que je
refasse in je n'ai pas dit madame forest
mais c'est pas grave
en spontanéité 1 alors ok alors je
voudrais me florence vous vous permettez
de vous appeler florence bien sûr vous
n'êtes pas monsieur eddy plomb flons
flons flons aller comment vous êtes là
tout de suite premières impressions
bonne ça on est content déjà un rythme
on a bossé tout l'été pour vous
accueillir comme il se doit mais ça vous
étiez très occupé donc rare donc on est
d'autant plus fière de vous avoir ici
merci j'ai le droit de m'asseoir vous
avez le malheur des ambulants vous avez
ya tellement de petites références de
repérer des petites choses à reporter
discrètement à la fin c'est super a
remarqué vous avez vous avez bossé
florence écrire tourner raconté imaginer
est ce que vous aviez un manque de nous
un peu un manque de public ah j'avais un
manque de public ah oui oui j'avais un
manque de public mais
j'ai l'habitude de marc était toujours
entre deux spectacles deux ans ou trois
ans donc ça savage oger quand même faut
pas déconner je peux vivre sans le
public pas longtemps mais je peux bon
nous vous nous avez manqué à la cci le
public dont je fais partie bien entendu
c'est évidemment de vous dont vous allez
nous parler dans ce canapé et par
sagement parce que vous allez nous
parler de vous aussi à travers cette
série qu'on a hâte de découvrir ce soit
le 3 octobre elle parle de vous cette
série des épisodes de 30 minutes qui
s'appelle désordre une création
originale canal plus après on parlera du
spectacle bien sûr mais franchement on
va dire toute la vérité rien que la
vérité ici l'aspect min est ce que dans
des ordres vous dit toute la vérité
florence
presque un an presque franchement en
fait c'est un peu le prolongement de mes
spectacles désordre c'est à dire que
j'ai l'impression que j'ai construit un
truc avec le public enfin en tout cas
avec le public qui m'est fidèle c'est à
dire qu'ils me suivent
depuis longtemps et désordre c'est un
peu leur ouvrir la porte des coulisses
voilà c'est un peu
en savoir plus mais évidemment tout en
gardant
la comédie comme comme leitmotiv tout en
gare et puis tout temps fictionné
évidemment on n'est pas du tout sur un
documentaire on n'est pas du tout sûr un
ego trip je crois sert qu'à l'image de
mes spectacles ce que j'essaie de faire
c'est de me servir de mon expérience
pour le rendre un peu universel et pour
essayer de de toucher les autres c'est
tout ce qui m'intéresse ouais alors on
va bien sûr regardez un extrait on va se
parler de ça avec du spectacle boys boys
boys dans la foulée d'abord voulais pas
faire un petit tour à paris dans le
marais à 6 abbassi saaba téléportation à
regarder vous avez juste à vous tourner
vers la crise voire même à prolonger le
mouvement si vous voulez vers la gauche
on va regarder cette baie vitrée a fait
palmarin obama a fait ce qu'on peut
vous me changer tout ça pas du tout ma
mais vous c'est le marais un c'est ça
c'est le marais ou rien dans paris